ça lui revint dit non tu fais pipi
comment toi bats comme ça non mais je
voulais dire debout ou assis un bon ben
je termine j'espère que vous êtes en
forme parce qu'aujourd'hui on va
s'attaquer à un gros morceau c'est à la
fois un grand mystère qui a traversé les
siècles et un sortilège magnifique
capable de transformer un prince
charmant en crapaud mais quel est ce
prodige me demanderez-vous
[Musique]
c'est comme ça ça a beau être une source
séculaire de différends conjugaux de
dispute entre amis ça a volé des goûters
eux même de s'asseoir sur des toiles est
humide et souillée rien n'y change les
hommes urinent sur la cuvette que je
propose c'est de voir ensemble pourquoi
mais aussi si des solutions sont
possibles
on comprendre le phénomène il faut bien
le disséquer et l'analyser point par
point
si les hommes urinent sur la cuvette
c'est parce que le jet du rin peut
parfois être difficile à maîtriser
d'abord il arrive qu'une forte envie
d'uriner provoque un début d'érection
une demi molle comme on dit dans le
jargon
ce qui rend la visée plus complexe
ensuite il via les variations pression
liée à la poussée un peu comme quand on
ferme un robinet et qu'on leur ouvre à
fond ça gicle et sinti rares anticipa le
coût peut partir dans le décor autre
problème qui peut dérégler la mire les
anomalies du gène l'urètre peut avoir
des petits problèmes ça va de la simple
inflammation à l'infection en passant
par la sténose c'est à dire le
rétrécissement et comme c'est par
l'urètre que sort green situé au est
déformé le j'ai aussi on peut avoir des
jets en deux parties qui partent dans
des directions opposées
certains appellent ça le str habite mais
le vrai nom c'est le jet bifide dans
certains cas on parle aussi de jets en
arrosoir ou en spirale dont vous dire
que c'est pas facile de viser bon ça
c'est pour les aléas de la vie il ya
aussi une raison qu'on rencontre au
quotidien puisqu'elle est directement
liée à l'anatomie du pénis et du système
urinaire masculin en général cette
particularité lève notamment le voile
sur un phénomène sur lequel les plus
grands érudits se sont penchés à travers
les siècles
[Musique]
ou qu'on agite la dernière vous
la fameuse dernière goutte qui apparaît
quand on croit que tout est terminé et
qui peut souiller les sous vêtements
le pantalon ou la cuvette suivant le
moment auquel elle fait son apparition
tout en espièglerie
là encore tout se passe au niveau de
l'urètre
mais pour bien comprendre il faut
remonter un peu avant la sortie y aurait
une part de la vessie et avant de
découvrir la lumière du jour elle
effectue son voyage le long de l'urètre
lequel comme la vie n'est pas un long
fleuve
en effet comme vous le constatez il
connaît quelques méandres comme celui ci
qui nous intéresse particulièrement du
fait de sa forme et de son emplacement
lui rinne a tendance à stagner comme de
l'eau dans une boucle de tuyaux
d'arrosage
elle a fini par se vider que quand la
position du corps et de la verge fait
passer la zone par dessus tout le reste
un peu comme quand on lâche le tuyau
d'arrosage un peu comme quand on sert le
thé aussi il y à une solution à ce
problème
c'est un truc d'ostéopathe et pour
réaliser la manoeuvre d'un simple doit
suffire
il faut le placer entre l'anus et les
testicules à l'endroit où lurette passe
d'ailleurs vous allez sentir la
vibration conlure et une passe et si
vous appuyez ça m'a coupé judd
voilà comment on fait une fois que vous
avez terminé votre petite affaire appuyé
en faisant un mouvement de l'arrière
vers l'avant pour forcer l'uriné se
diriger vers la sortie
c'est comme quand on vit dans un sachet
de mayonnaise voilà le tour est joué
il ne vous reste plus qu'à vous laver
les mains bon c'est un peu du bricolage
on va pas se mentir on va pas éludé le
coeur du problème si les hommes urinent
sur la cuvette c'est avant tout parce
qu'il urine de doux là encore essayons
de comprendre pourquoi les hommes du rin
debout alors qu'il en met partout dans
cette position la première explication
est toute simple les hommes urines de
vous parce qu'ils peuvent et que c'est
bien pratique toutes les femmes
conseiller de piste de vous dire on est
il urine de vous parce qu'on leur en
donne très souvent la possibilité voire
l'obligation
le problème c'est que c'est tellement
pratique qui prennent l'habitude et du
coup même quand il pourra uriner à si
elles le font pas surtout si l urine sur
la lunette c'est dégueulasse mais
j'entends d'autres arguments d'abord
qu'il existera une sorte de fierté
masculine à uriner debout une garde de
l'enfant cde la première fois on arrive
à faire comme papa
bon alors disons qu'on est en 2017 et
que j'imagine
on doit pouvoir trouver des motifs
destine de soi ailleurs que dans la
position dans laquelle on vit de sa
vessie de pente
et puis il y à l'argument de la position
anatomique un homme c'était pour uriner
d'ailleurs tout le monde fait comme ça
là bas n'ont pas tout le monde un tiers
des hommes japonais urines à six et dans
d'autres pays ça se fait accroupis donc
nous en réalité rien ne permet
d'affirmer qu' anatomiquement les hommes
ne doivent pas uriner assis leur petit
matériel est parfaitement adapté à cette
position
c'est même conseillé à certains patients
atteints de troubles du bas appareil
urinaire
parce que les muscles sont plus détendus
et que ça permet une meilleure vie
d'ange de la vessie donc la barrière est
purement psychologiques et culturels
alors attention ne tombons pas dans
l'excès inverse comme bigot en scène qui
est un homme politique suédois qui
voulait faire voter une loi pour obliger
les hommes à uriner ainsi alors
admettons mais pour convaincre tout le
monde le bonhomme avait avancé deux
arguments uriner ainsi diminuerait le
risque de cancer de la prostate et sa
garantirait une vie sexuelle meilleure
et plus longue
dans les deux cas ça ne repose sur rien
de scientifique donc les gars si vous
décidez de vous mettre à uriner à 6
faites le mais faites-le pour des bonnes
raisons comme ne pas en mettre partout
par exemple et vous voir ce qu'est votre
smartphone sans risque et en tout
confort
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos en attendant
mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]